a
[Música]
con el aumento de la ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos en
ciudades como bogotá o medellín y el
incremento de los contagios que ya
superan los 18 millones en colombia cada
vez son más las críticas contra las
autoridades respecto al proceso de
vacunación mientras otros países de la
región ya comenzaron a inyectar las
dosis en colombia aún no hay fechas
claras sobre cuándo comenzará a inocular
a su población hasta el momento el
presidente iván duque ha acordado la
compra de 10 millones de cada una de las
vacunas conjuntas pzifer bayón tec y
astrazéneca oxford así como 9 millones
de la inyección de la farmacéutica
johnson and johnson y otros 20 millones
a través de kóvacs el mecanismo
coordinado de la o ms además el
ministerio de salud se ha hecho público
el documento con el plan nacional en dos
fases cinco etapas con el que el
gobierno quiere vacunar a más de 35
millones de ciudadanos y alcanzar así la
inmunidad de rebaño
[Música]
pero en ser un acuerdo con el
laboratorio chino sino farm para comprar
38 millones de dosis de su vacuna contra
el coi 19 las autoridades recibirán un
millón de dosis entre enero y febrero
para comenzar la vacunación se espera
inmunizar entre 14 y 15 millones de
peruanos hasta antes de la temporada de
invierno por otro lado el gobierno
peruano también concretó un contrato con
astrazéneca oxford inglaterra para
acceder a 14 millones de vacunas a
partir de septiembre del 2021
en paralelo se obtendrán más de 13
millones de dosis mediante la coalición
kóvacs facilite que arribarán al país en
el tercer trimestre del año la compra de
las vacunas generaron reacciones
diversas mientras un sector del país
aplaude la gestión de francisco sagasti
un 40 por ciento de ciudadanos afirman
que no tiene intenciones de ser
inmunizados mientras tanto desde el
parlamento algunos congresistas exigen
que sea el propio francisco sagasti el
primero en ser vacunado porque dudan de
la efectividad del medicamento
desarrollado por scinopharm
[Música]
semana decisiva en brasil el próximo
domingo 17 de enero la anvisa que es el
órgano regulador del ministerio de
sanidad tiene que decidir si aprueba el
uso de emergencia de las dos vacunas que
están siendo desarrolladas en territorio
brasileño la de laboratorio astrazéneca
y la china sinovac la fecha de limpieza
de la vacunación está haciendo el objeto
de una pelea política entre algunos
gobernadores y el presidente del país y
jair bolsonaro de hecho los estados de
sao paulo y río de janeiro los más
afectados por la pandemia aseguran que
el 25 de enero empieza la vacunación
mientras tanto el ministro de sanidad
que ha sido criticado por su lentitud
dice que no que todos los 27 estados de
brasil comenzarán al mismo tiempo y que
puede ser incluso antes el 20 de enero
lo que sí sabemos es que vacunar a los
212 millones de brasileños va a ser todo
un reto es el país más populoso del
continente y el segundo más afectado por
la pandemia en el mundo con casi 205 mil
muertos
[Música]